we're here to talk about guitar hero
live yeah Escott Butterworth you have
reviewed this game have or gamespot com
yes the review is up now what did you
give it give it a six out of ten six out
of ten which was a bit lower than what a
lot of other people gave the game I was
actually a little surprised to see that
so many of the other scores were
consistently higher than mine i'm
currently the lowest review on
metacritic witching i'm like i said a
little bit surprised and also lower than
you gave rock bands by a point yes i
gave rock band 4 7 out of 10 yes so
let's talk about what's in guitar your
life because you're there's lots of
different messaging there's two games
coming out they've all got different
systems and I gonna have to say that
probably one of the most difficult parts
for your reviewing this game must have
been trying to just communicate what if
this game is yes it's not just what's on
the disk it's uh it was a complicated
review in part because yes the game
itself is complicated there's a lot
going on in the game it tries to do a
lot of different things a lot of new
things but I also have very conflicting
feelings about the game very extreme you
know polar opposite feelings of a lot of
the different aspects are trying to
reconcile all those feelings and
synthesize them into a cohesive review
proved very difficult so what are those
sections is like a campaign and then
there's the easiest way to boiled and
writers like campaign and then like
we're using service thing correct yeah
it's that's basically what the game is
like the package Guitar Hero live the
game comes with guitar hero live which
is a campaign 42 songs over live footage
custom created shop of the first person
camera make it look like you're on stage
that's all of this stuff that's what
you're looking on the screen right now
and then there's also Guitar Hero TV
which is sort of a music streaming
service thing it's difficult to describe
because it's not entirely like any other
service out there which does make it
interesting but it also has some really
frustrating aspects to its setup let's
get the inside out in a second for the
moment though let's talk about at the
previous the first person campaign II
stuff sure what is that like is that are
those song set in motion are they like
the same songs everyone's going to play
throughout the campaign are you playing
in different places and first person
like how does it work so the way that
guitar hero live is structure it is
basically you have a bunch of sets that
are structured that under an umbrella of
you're playing two different music fests
and there are different band
playing different sets different times
each set is a preset list of songs there
are 42 on disc songs that's what this
campaign is using so over the course of
that entire campaign you play each song
as the sort of fake band within you know
set up again is fastest and sets and
things within that and you get you know
each band has a sort of different look
about them and and sticks with in this
sort of genre of music but all of it is
really goofy an authentic and just kind
of bizarre Justin Salyer you chime in
well unlike the previous games you're
not creating your own band like this is
all set up but for me like I feel like
it's really cool whenever i watch that
footage of getting that first person
shot of the crowd and looking out and
like playing bigger and bigger venues
and that feels like it would add a lot
of excitement like being there like I'm
actually playing the concert at looking
at look at the ladies for instance this
look at this for setup yeah like I'm
actually at the Carter he's gonna help
me get up the stairs if I were playing
this in virtual reality I this would
blow my mind it does it or can you even
like you even notice because are you
just looking at your notes on the screen
so that's the thing when you're actually
playing a song no you you kind of don't
which i think is a big part of why the
motions and they acting everything are
so exaggerated they kind of a sign
you're only gonna be watching it from
out of the corner of your eye on acela
so yeah so everything is so hammy and
played up and over the top like every
thumbs up is just like really
ridiculously exaggerated wasn't there
someone with a sign of once agent says
you're your there are a bunch of like
weird generic like they're like you're
cool or like good job band like it's
just it's very good job back you know I
don't think that's word from over in it
but it's very 0 and 1 like if you're
doing a good job you see good stuff
you're doing a bad job you see bad stuff
it's not like a transitions it's a very
poor boy wait wait wait is this Tony
Hawk 5 what's going on yes that's the
thing so so first what Justin was saying
is true yes there's good it's either
you're doing well or you're doing poorly
that's it there's no in-between and it's
the the two were very extreme I mean
you're either like a 70 v you're either
an irredeemable embarrassment or an
absolute guitar I mean this guy's got a
skateboard he's an embarrassment but
yeah then so then the other portion of
it that really I found kind of grading
is that it's just so inauthentic it just
is not a beautiful
we before is anyway nothing about it
yeah it's like the most enthusiastic
rodeos ever existed like a parody but
there's nothing about it that is sort of
self-aware or silly or plate okay ladies
son is this I guess any bellman must
have shot this it's a boy with a fellow
producer Josh yeah Josh Shaw Astrid
wanted to show at the moment in the back
and then there's Bob his biggest fan you
are cool ah this is great oh I i would
pay for this as dlc are we oh really can
we do that we're in talks right now to
bring this to the game and so when
you're playing Lee said when you're
playing the single-player campaign you
you have some songs that are unlocked
where you can you can do it quickly but
you actually it's a very it's a
throwback to older Guitar Hero games and
all the rocking games you have to play
every song in order to unlock them a
quick plane plane with another person
yeah there's a lot of sort of annoying
throwback stuff like that yeah so if you
want to just jump in and play with your
friends you really kinda can't like this
campaign is single player only so all
the videos if you're watching it was
built for you know a guitarist right
shopping first person so there is local
multiplayer stuff as well he can do yes
so you can jump into quick play with in
life but all of the songs except for the
first track from each set is locked so
you have to actually play the single
player by yourself to unlock the tracks
in order to play them in quick play
which is like didn't we decide ten years
ago that that was a bad idea and that
you should just be able to access
content right out of the gate I mean
that why you motivate those a game like
why gate the content like that it's just
silly and that's just one of a handful
of examples of that kind of strange you
know step back for example if you ever
pause the game it'll it'll count you
back in but it's the same counter
regardless of the tempo of the song or
where you are in the song so absolutely
when it starts you back up you're gonna
miss several notes is like I mean rock
band handles that a lot better i mean
again they're just a lot of examples
like that where it says it could have
used some polish and there's such easy
things to fix and stuff that was
resolved years ago and it just kind of
backpedals on it's weird let's also talk
then about the actual songs because
that's we know one of the most important
parts of of a game like this in your
review i read that i guess most of the
songs from this are taken from like top
40 for the past five years pretty much
actually papi stuff yes it's a it's
primarily focused on top 40 pop music
not a lot like in previous games would
in in rock band I think especially
there's a good job of this it'll pick
songs that even if you don't know them
they are appropriate for the gameplay
yeah there is you know an interesting
guitar hook or you know the guitarist or
the focus there's something about the
Song musically that makes it interesting
and fun to play yeah with a lot of these
songs they're popular and you'll
probably recognize them because yes
they're all like top 40 major label
songs from the past five or so years yet
with only a small handful of exceptions
but a lot of them are not built for this
kind of game play they'll have like one
single line or you know guitar hook
they'll repeat for the entire verse and
this you'll play the course that'll go
right back to the verse and ultimately
the song will have just like three
different parts over its entire duration
but it's just not fun to play and then
you also get stuff like Skrillex or
Eminem yes I'm getting like really
popular artists but those songs like the
Skrillex song literally doesn't have
guitar in it no wait well Skrillex were
like 10 seconds of a guitar lick and
then the rest of the song no guitar but
you are playing so you're playing like
the synthes sounds and dubstep noises
it's but it's just while you're making a
game called guitar hero why would you
not pay music that's guitar-driven
there's so much good guitar driven music
why would you pick these songs it's just
it doesn't make sense so that's on the
sort of Guitar Hero live campaign stuff
yeah so explain what the other part of
this is because this looks interesting
in terms of at least the library music
that's a veil yeah so that's the sort of
natural segue between the two that
guitar hero tv offers way more music but
the way that it provides music is not
really like anything we've seen before
in a music game you know traditionally
you could buy a song as DLC and you
would own the song you play whenever
blah blah blah cotorreo TV does not do
that in fact you cannot buy songs you
cannot there's no way to permanently
unlock a song so you can just play it
whenever you like so how do you get
access the new songs so if you want to
play a particular song if there's
something that you find in the game's
song catalog you're like oh that's a
good one I want to play that song you
have to spend a play to play it just
that time okay it's it's like a one time
you spend a play you play the song and
you can't even restart the song to be
screw up I'm where you where do you get
the place so you accumulate plays uh
basically every thing you play
Guitar Hero TV even the stuff that
you're paying to play or spending place
to pay to play that's confusing covert
uh everything you play you get coins and
coins you can spend on plays or you can
spend like custom god no tracks and
stuff like that you get those in the
campaign as well there is that oh no
it's okay cific to guitar here t da and
you can also have any sub real world
currency like you even said actual cash
to buy plays yes but you don't have to
you can you know accumulate coins by
playing the game has been down to you
accumulate coins to get play see that
that's the thing not so a single play
when you play a song you are not earning
enough coins to buy another place so
inevitable you're going to run out of
place the game is pretty generous up
front by giving you chunks of plays like
you beat the tutorial and it
automatically gives you oh here's 10 PX
spend them on whatever we want to get
you into our marketplace yeah do you
know how many songs is it like three
songs a little verse two hundred songs
know in terms of how many times used to
play to get one of these yeah so two to
three songs depending on your
performance will write net you enough
coin to purchase a play but then you can
also buy them with your own money what's
the rate on that uh so you can of 10
pack a place cost you about not about it
cost you two dollars and fifty cents
okay for 10 hurt for 10 plays but again
the game is relatively generous up front
it'll just give you chunks of plays and
you are earning currency no matter what
you play and the primary way to earn
currency if you're not just spending
plays on the songs you want to play is
the guitar hero channels so basically
the way the channels work is there are
two of them they offer different
programming generally one's gonna be
more pop focus one's going to be like
rock and metal focus and it's just a
constant stream of preset music videos
kind of like old-school MTV like you get
tuned in to mtv airing Tue and it would
just be there just playing music before
last FM radio or Spotify radio or any
one of those services the sort of like
here's a bunch of music although unlike
something like say Pandora you can't put
in suggestions it's just whatever the
game is playing that's what you're going
to play well unlike Spotify as well
Spotify you can pick songs you get to
choose like here's the thing that I want
to play and this is more like
grooveshark where it's like and I'm
gonna play these and in the so there's
channel set up like you are gonna play
songs that are kind of within a genre so
like but there's only two channels so
the delineation is like really they're
in very big buckets and that's all much
separate that's all
yes the Challenger absolutely free it's
like fun cuz that's a good type of
discovery as well of forces people yeah
and it wouldn't like was where I broke
from most other reviewers a lot of
people seem to really enjoy the channels
I really don't really and the main
reason why is I just want to have more
control over what I'm playing nicely at
sixty dollars no sorry hunter spent a
hundred dollars if you have to get the
new guitar you can't play this game
without the new guitar that comes with
it which makes sense and we'll get to
that in a minute because the game plays
yeah awesome but to finish up with
guitar hero TV the channels that you
can't you can't even skip us on I mean
seriously it's it's like television
where whatever is on is what you're
playing so if something comes on I hate
this artist or I hate this song there's
nothing fun you're just either they're
stuck playing it or you quit and you go
play something else assuming you have
the places to go pick us on you actually
enjoy and to me that just feels weird
and I feel like it kind of very it just
funnels you into the micro transaction
system so you can technically play
without paying I presumably a couple of
more channels might have fixed this
problem and they are planning on adding
a third channel but they haven't even
indicated what a channel will be like I
haven't talked about that genre block
will be split in half so it's it's the
whole system just feels weird to me
because it's like if you have to worry
about having enough currency to play the
content you want it fundamentally
changes how you're even thinking about
the experience like is it worth spending
a player to play that song or Who am I
gonna really have enough and you know do
I need to grind through songs during
coins and I don't want to think about
that type of game certainly feels like
it's gonna be damned to like the
consumer like are they comfortable with
it to me yes and that sounds like
something I might not be into but aside
from Nash let's talk about the sort of
the physical aspect of this yeah the new
guitar doesn't play well does it feel
like you're learning how to play guitar
hero again like i say my review the
mechanics are really what redeemed the
entire game for me i feel like it really
does successfully reinvent just the core
mechanics that drive the entire genre
and that's a serious accomplishment I
mean that took some real thinking and
some deft execution to even make that so
why that you mean so the way that it
works now is traditionally you had five
buttons all in a row just linear right
and that you know what sort of made a
tricky was you had to extend your pinky
down or move your entire hand to get to
that last note right
so the way that this new guitar works is
it's actually six buttons and they're
laid out sort of side by side so you
have three buttons on sort of the upper
part of the neck closer to your body and
then three buttons directly underneath
that closer to the floor so you're
switching not only up and down on the
fretboard but back and forth between one
side and the other and so that allows
for a lot of really interesting new
patterns and variations in the note
charts and it does force you to
completely relearn the way that you play
these games which is exciting because it
makes it feel fresh and new again and
just the process of learning and
developing your skills is super
rewarding it's always been rewarding
it's what made the genre such a hit in
the first place or a big part of it
anyway excellent so to recapture that
and make it new is like that's the huge
guitar your life six out of 10 on
gamespot com yes and I guess wait and
see if that's the sort of type of mod
Leona by is there dlc coming out first
they do they've stated that they plan to
continue to add songs guitar hero TV
writer my plans are slightly vague but
from what I've heard they want at least
17 new songs in by the end figure
they're gonna funnel people into that
aspect though yes alright Justin skull
thank you so much for coming on and
talking this is all about guitar hero
lie gore hat will be